Y es que América también se divide en se
divide también en torno a varios temas
china es uno de ellos por ejemplo hace
poco se conoció que Honduras se sumó a
los países que rompieron relaciones con
Taiwán debe ser esto una preocupación
preocupa esto al continente preocupa
Estados Unidos que digamos ve como su
histórico partido trasero alguna forma
está siendo copado por china a través de
inversiones y demás el único país que
digamos resiste esa presión china es
Paraguay de alguna forma tiene una
consistencia histórica muy digamos
digamos notable pero digamos el resto de
América Latina ha girado un poco en
torno a mirar hacia china como un nuevo
proveedor de inversiones un nuevo
proveedor digamos de digamos hacia de
exportaciones de materias primas y
manufacturados cuál es el asunto Que
obviamente lo que más preocupa es la
relación que se pueda tener con
Washington y en ese sentido los países
de América Latina están en un equilibrio
un poco embarazoso y es mientras reciben
la ayuda de de china en términos de
ayudas para el desarrollo de
infraestructura Pues digamos el consenso
frente a Estados Unidos como el hegemón
regional por lo menos o el digamos el
policía del mundo el gendarme del mundo
Pues también queda un poco debatible
allí entonces de alguna forma los países
de América Latina están en un equilibrio
un poco embarazoso entre recibir la
ayuda China y seguir los postulados de
los Estados Unidos en términos de lo que
puede ser la política internacional